i i read it uh
later in my life i think uh i read it
first time when i was a a graduate
student
and that's the soldier nissan's cancer
ward
that is an amazingly powerful book
it's what is it about it's about i mean
essentially based on on
uh you know solzhenitsyn uh uh was
diagnosed with cancer when
he was reasonably young and he he made a
full recovery
but uh you know so so this is about a
a a person who was sentenced for life
in one of these uh you know uh camps
and he had some cancer
so he was uh you know transported back
to one of these
uh soviet republics i think it was
you know south asian republics and
uh the the book is about
you know his experience
being a a prisoner being
a you know a patient in the cancer
clinic in a cancer ward surrounded by
people many of which
die right but
in a way you know the way i you know it
reads i mean first of all
later on i i uh read the the accounts of
the
of the doctors who described this
you know the the experiences uh you know
uh
in the book by the patient as as
incredibly accurate right so so
you know i i read that there was you
know some doctors saying that you know
every single doctor should read this
book to understand
what the patient fields but
you know again as many of the society
needs books
it has multiple levels of complexity and
obviously the the
you know if you look above the cancer
and the patient
i mean the the the humor that was
growing
and then disappeared in in
in his uh you know uh in his body with
some consequences
i mean this is you know allegorically
the soviet yeah and and
you know and he actually he he agree you
know when he was
asked he said that this is what make him
think about this you know how to combine
these experiences
him being a part of the you know of the
soviet regime
also being a part of the of the you know
of
someone sent to the to gulag camp
right and also someone who who
experienced
cancer in his life you know the uh the
good luck archipelago
and this book these are the works that
actually made him uh you know receive a
nobel prize
but you know to me i i've uh you know
i've
read different other uh you know uh
books by solzhenitsyn this one is to me
is the most powerful one
and by the way both this one and the
previous one you write in russian
yes yes
you